Alors, voyons ça
Putain, mais c'est quoi ça?!
*Musique*
Allez, vas-y
Elle est pas tranquille
*Intro*
C'est aujourd'hui que je me fais tatouer les fesses
Je ne sais pas trop à quoi m'attendre en terme de douleur
Par contre je sais à quoi m'attendre en terme de réaction
Parce que pas mal de gens ont déjà essayé de m'en dissuader
A commencer par ma copine et mes enfants
Qui m'ont littéralement imploré de pas faire ça.
Ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que si tout le monde m'a imploré comme ça
C'est parce que je vais me faire tatouer Cyril Hanouna sur les fesses
Pour le bien de la science, allez go!
Alors, avant d'aller se faire tatouer le cul, toujours se faire couper les cheveux, c'est un principe. J'y vais.
Putain, ça devient urgent, on dirait Pierre Croce là. (*Alors évidemment*)
Voilà, c'est fait, maintenant je vais manger un morceau parce que se faire tatouer le cul l'estomac vide
à mon avis, c'est pas une bonne idée. On est partis
C'est important d'avoir quelque chose à vomir si je fais un malaise
Alors on y est presque, on approche, il fait hyper froid, je ne suis pas sur que
ce soit le bon jour pour se mettre cul nu, 'fin j'imagine que le salon est chauffé
On va retrouver bientôt Romain, l'ami Romain qui doit attendre, ou être en retard..
Et plutôt en retard à priori !
Alors Romain n'est pas juste en retard, il était en retard
Il était en route et il s'est rendu compte qu'il avait oublié du matos chez lui
Donc il est retourné le chercher chez lui, donc il est en retard tout en étant en retard
..en étant encore plus en retard
C'est même plus un talent à ce niveau là, c'est de l'art!
Donc comme moi j'ai toujours aussi froid, je me balade dans le quartier en attendant de pouvoir me faire tatouer le cul.
Ca fait monter un peu la pression, c'est cool. Merci Romain!
J. Menielle: Il est arrivé le champion   Romain: Jamais en retard
(J.M) De bonne heure et de bonne humeur
Ca y est on y est, est-ce que là c'est trop tard pour reCULer?
C'est bon, allez on y va!
Julien c'est quand tu veux
Julien: Moi c'est bon. JM: Allez c'est parti
Franchement.. Ca va
Ca pique un peu, mais ça va, j'ai pas encore pleuré
C'est marrant parce qu'il y a des endroits quand ils tatouent,
J'ai le muscle qui se contracte tout seul
Comme les sport elec
Ce qui me fait le plus peur moi, c'est de lâcher une caisse en fait
J'ai mangé un burger aux oignons
Son de GoPro n°2 *clap*
Tatoueur: Tu m'as fait peur toi! Ingé Son: Désolé
J.M: Ne le fais pas sursauter
Le plus déstabilisant c'est d'avoir une personne que tu connais aussi peu aussi proche de ton anus en fait
Allez
Ah bah regarde.. magique
Changement d'équipe, passage de relais
Donc là c'est Ama qui a pris le relais, Ama qui a deux particularités
La première c'est d'être tatoueuse et la deuxième c'est d'être le sosie de Shy'm
*Musique de Shy'm*
C'est la première fois que Shy'm est aussi près de mes fesses
Vraiment
Final *clap*
Et voilà.. C'est fait
Voilà venu le moment où ma douce et tendre va découvrir la bête
La douce et tendre: Oh putain de merde!                    Julien: Héhéhé
A la fois je te trouve merveilleux, et à la fois je te déteste! Mais tu me dégoûte un peu
*Musique d'outro*